Okay. It's time for hatred at male hatred.
Male is when a professional voiceover artist
does readings of hatred that mail that I get
a very special hatred at mail today. But before
we get into that, just a quick reminder of
what hatred at mail is.
Rand and Ronald Reagan had a baby and suckled
that child off the teat of liberty. It's cries
would sound a little something like a treadmill
written by patriots who hate David Pakman
because America and because freedom.
Okay. So this, um, this week's hatred at mail
is extraordinarily disturbing as are most
of them, but it actually includes a, a sort
of hearkening back to one of my favorite video
games. Growing up. Didn't play a lot of video
games growing up, but I loved the Mario series
and there is a probably offensive to Italian
people, a reference to that game. Uh, in this
week's Patriot Mel, take a listen to this.
Eats a CC boy then likes a chasing a ghost.
David, please look at the mirror. That is
the most moronic face ever live. His name
is David Pacman, you know, Hook, sadly right
the left, our God drain mega 2020 Trump is
the answer to unhinged left leftism.
I've got to hand it to them. It's a little
bit clever and the great interpretive reading
from hatred at mail guy makes it a lot more
clever, but it doesn't change the fact that
hatred hate it when the David Pakman show
does well. And one of the ways you can really
anger the hatred cuts is by signing up for
a membership@davidpakman.com slash membership
using the coupon code tree at 40 h a t r I
o t 40. That saves you 40% and it's like a
double middle finger to the hatred. So I encourage
you to, uh, encourage you to take advantage
of that.